Traduttore: Giada Maffi
Revisore: Asia Carafa
(Musica)
Marco Confortola: Bentrovati.
Vi accompagnerò pian piano
in un mondo magico.
Il mondo della montagna.
Un mondo bellissimo, fantastico,
(Video: Siamo partiti dal campo base oggi)
(Video: Facciamo un test)
dove per vivere bisogna essere
(Video: saliamo se riusciamo fino al campo 2)
assolutamente connessi
(Video: e vediamo
se effettivamente l'acclimatamento...)
Sono nato connesso
fondamentalmente.
Vivo in Valtellina,
vivo in un luogo magico,
dove la montagna ce l'abbiamo nel sangue.
E proprio qui stavo vedendo
le immagini del K2,
quella montagna
che ho sempre sognato fin da piccolino.
Perché uno dei primi salitori sul K2,
Achille Compagnoni nel '54,
tutti gli anni il 31 luglio in Valfurva
raccontava la sua salita.
Io mi sono innamorato di quella montagna.
Mi sono innamorato
di quella montagna perfetta: il K2.
Il K2 è la montagna degli italiani.
È la seconda montagna
più alta del mondo con gli 8.611 m.
Il K2 l'ho salito il 1 agosto 2008
senza ossigeno.
Lassù ho bivaccato a 8.400 m,
perché la mia connessione
con la montagna non c'era più.
C'era qualcosa che non funzionava.
C'era qualcosa che non andava bene.
Mi sono fermato, ho bivaccato
e poi ho ritrovato
la connessione per continuare.
Ho passato la notte a 8.400 metri.
Senza cibo, senza tenda,
sacco a pelo, senza niente.
E mi sono dovuto connettere
perfettamente alla montagna
per riuscire a stare sveglio,
per non morire.
Perché là sopra a quelle quote,
dopo aver salito il K2 senza ossigeno,
è semplice perdere la connessione,
è semplice lasciarsi andare
ed è semplice morire.
Ho bivaccato su quella montagna difficile.
Una montagna tecnicamente
non semplice da affrontare.
Una montagna che per salirla
devi essere molto allenato e preparato.
Quella montagna mi ha lasciato
il dono più prezioso
che tutti noi abbiamo: la vita.
Dopo quel bivacco, purtroppo,
sono morte quella notte undici persone.
Sono sceso dalla montagna
con dei grossi problemi
legati al congelamento.
Scalare su quelle montagne
non è assolutamente semplice.
Bisogna essere precisi, allenati,
avere conoscenza, essere determinati,
per raggiungere
la cima di queste montagne.
Per scalare non solo
le montagne dell'Himalaya,
ma tutte le montagne,
per affrontare il mio mondo,
che è il mondo particolare
di una guida alpina, di un himalayista,
di un formatore, di un elisoccorritore
e, a volte oso definirmi,
un creatore di sogni e sorrisi,
bisogna essere connessi sempre.
Sempre.
La vita è una connessione
fondamentalmente,
ma là bisogna essere molto attenti
a essere tutto questo.
È una montagna difficile da affrontare.
Il continuare dal campo base,
andare verso il campo 1, dormire,
poi campo 2, poi ridiscendere
al campo base, riposare,
poi tornare su al campo 1,
al campo 2, campo 3, dormire,
poi tornare giù al campo base:
questo è l'acclimatamento.
L'acclimatamento serve
per stressare il corpo umano,
per riuscire a mettere in atto
una variazione a livello di sangue,
di ematocrito, di globuli rossi
per far sí che il nostro corpo
riesca a salire là sopra
dove manca l'ossigeno
e per andare in vetta,
in questo caso al K2.
Il 1 agosto del 2008
ero in vetta alla mia montagna.
Il mio sogno, il K2.
La discesa è stata purtroppo tragica.
Quella notte sono morte 11 persone.
Per la lunga permanenza in quota,
sono rimasto ben tre giorni
sopra gli 8.000m dopo il bivacco,
i miei piedi sono congelati.
E questa è una difesa del corpo umano
perché il corpo umano
è una macchina perfetta.
E dopo quel congelamento
mi è cambiata completamente la vita.
Io sono amputato:
a me mancano dieci dita dei piedi.
Io ho perso una connessione
e ho dovuto riaprirne un'altra.
Ho dovuto reimparare a camminare.
Non è stato semplice assolutamente.
Non è semplice affrontare
un'amputazione per un alpinista
che, tra virgolette, lavora con i piedi.
Gli alpinisti scalano, arrampicano
e sciano con i piedi e con le mani.
Perdere una parte del tuo corpo,
in questo caso dieci dita dei piedi,
è un problema per un alpinista.
Correre, sciare, arrampicare, scalare
è un problema senza le dita dei piedi.
Ad un certo punto,
quando mi hanno accompagnato a Padova,
dove c'è un medico
preparatissimo su questo,
un chirurgo vascolare che mi ha curato
mi ha preso nelle sue braccia
come un bambino
e pian piano mi ha fatto ritornare
nel mio mondo.
Ma per tornare non è stato semplice.
Ad un certo punto dopo l'amputazione,
io ho staccato tutto.
Non ero più connesso
con il mondo al di fuori di me.
Attorno non c'era più nessuno.
Pensavo solo a me stesso.
Ero diventato automaticamente egoista.
Pensavo solo a me,
solo alla mia vita, ai miei piedi.
I miei piedi che, automaticamente
in questa pedicure pesante,
sono diventati corti.
(Musica)
Però, con tanta forza di volontà...
Di fatto io ho un mio pensiero,
che non è poi neanche mio:
No pain, no gain
Se non soffri,
non raggiungi gli obiettivi.
Sono tornato.
Dopo un anno
ho reimparato a camminare.
Pian piano sono tornato a 8.000 m,
con tanto allenamento.
Per me la connessione
è una cosa scontata e semplice.
Il mio corpo, il mio brain (cervello)
è sempre connesso.
Io sono sempre connesso.
Io vivo e lavoro fuori dall'area comfort.
Non esiste per me l'area comfort.
Tutti i giorni cambia qualcosa
sia come guida alpina,
che come tecnico dell'elisoccorso,
come maestro di sci, come himalayista.
Cambia sempre tutto.
Per me è semplice.
Io sono sempre costantemente connesso.
La vita fondamentalmente
è una connessione.
Pensateci così, la vita è una connessione.
Questo è tratto dal mio mestiere:
questo è l'elisoccorso, come detto prima.
Questo è il soccorso
che abbiamo effettuato
nel 2017 al Dhaulagiri,
dove abbiamo salvato
7 alpinisti dell'esercito indiano.
In questo particolare soccorso,
la comunicazione, la fiducia,
la responsabilità, la conoscenza,
la connessione sono state fondamentali
per riuscire a portare a casa 7 persone
che stavano per morire là sopra
perchè dopo aver salito il Dhaulagiri
han finito l'ossigeno.
Non riuscivano più a scendere
verso il campo base
e andavano verso edemi cerebrali,
polmonari e congelamenti.
Siamo riusciti a portarli a casa.
Uno staff di italiani,
due piloti elisoccorso trentino
con un tecnico elisoccorso valtellinese.
Li abbiamo agganciati uno per uno
e li abbiamo portati tutti a casa.
Questo è l'Himalaya, questa è la montagna.
Capite benissimo che in montagna,
che è un luogo magico, bellissimo,
che non va assolutamente sottovalutato,
bisogna sempre essere connessi.
È una parola che penso a tanti
risuonerà nella mente, nei pensieri.
Ma questa è connessione:
essere sempre preparati e attenti.
E anche essere connessi proprio
con l'effetto natura, con la montagna.
Montagna, mare, effetto natura:
la forza non siamo noi, la forza è quella.
L'effetto natura è il mare e la montagna.
Qui stiamo scalando per andare
verso il campo 2 del Manaslu,
che è il mio primo ottomila
dopo l'amputazione.
Io l'ho dedicato ad un carissimo amico,
Marco Simoncelli,
che purtroppo se n'è andato.
Quell'ottomila è per lui.
là sopra per me
è stato un qualcosa di grandioso.
Il primo 8000 dopo l'amputazione.
L'amputazione è importante
per un alpinista,
perché, come detto in precedenza,
per scalare, arrampicare e sciare
contano tantissimo i piedi.
I nostri piedi sono dei sensori.
Fondamentalmente,
non avere quello cambia tutto.
Automaticamente cambia una connessione
e se ne trova un'altra.
Volere è potere.
Capite l'importanza, la resilienza
di tenere sempre duro, di mai mollare,
di aver sempre chiaro un obiettivo.
Parlo tantissimo ai bambini
e a livello aziendale.
Questa è la resilienza:
avere sempre chiaro un obiettivo
e mai mollare.
Ai bambini insegno i quattro comandamenti
che sono obbedire, studiare,
fare sport e mai mollare.
E sognare deve essere un dovere.
E con loro mi connetto sempre.
È importante, loro sono il nostro futuro.
Questa è la resilienza
che deve avere
un alpinista sugli ottomila.
Si sale, si dorme in quota e si scende.
Si riposa un pochettino al campo base,
poi si torna su, si ritraccia.
Bisogna essere resistenti
e avere conoscenza
per capire dove si sta andando.
È importante lo studio,
capire dove si va
e sempre essere connessi
alla montagna, alla natura.
Capire, sentirla.
Questa è connessione per me.
Questo è il Manaslu, il mio primo ottomila
che ho salito dopo l'amputazione.
L'amputazione importante
che non mi ha fermato.
Perché tanti hanno creduto
che Marco fosse finito.
Marco sta continuando,
perché sto cercando di raggiungere
questo grande sogno
che è il raggiungimento
di tutte le cime delle 14 montagne
più alte del mondo:
la corona degli ottomila.
Un progetto molto ambizioso
e ambito dagli alpinisti.
Non semplice da raggiungere,
che ti porta a tanti sacrifici.
Questo è un campo base,
siamo sempre al Manaslu.
Capite che per riuscire a fare certe cose
devi sempre avere una lucidità tale
per essere sempre preciso.
Devi avere sempre il tuo obiettivo.
Sapere fin dove si può osare
e quando si torna indietro.
Scrivo. A me piace scrivere.
Ho inventato un gioco,
per riuscire a fare capire
alle persone al di fuori del mio mondo
cosa vuole dire la montagna.
La montagna è magia,
ma sa anche essere spietata.
Per riuscire a far capire alle persone
fin dove si può andare,
a me piace scrivere.
E in questo caso, ho inventato
un gioco in scatola: "Sfida agli 8.000",
che insegna le regole base
per vivere la montagna in sicurezza.
Qui siamo sempre sulla montagna.
Stiamo salendo verso il campo 3.
Quella sopra è la vetta del Manaslu,
il mio primo ottomila dopo l'amputazione.
Qui stiamo vedendo
questi blocchi di ghiaccio
che sono una valanga
che purtroppo ha creato dei problemi
sul nostro percorso di salita.
Ma poi, pian piano
sempre con tanta determinazione,
abbiamo ritracciato la salita
verso il campo 3 e il campo 4,
per poi salire lassù,
dove il mondo è rotondo.
Perché su vedrete,
quando sbuco dalla cresta,
la sfericità della terra.
Là sopra si è talmente in alto
che il mondo si vede rotondo.
E non è un effetto ottico.
Perché sei talmente in alto,
pensate a 8.167 m vedi talmente lontano,
che il mondo è sferico.
È rotondo.
Certo, non serviva
che Confortola andasse lassù
per farvelo capire,
ma il mondo è rotondo.
(Risate)
Qui siamo al campo 4.
E qui siamo in vetta.
È un pianto liberatorio.
Un pianto di soddisfazione personale
perché sono tornato lassù
dopo quello che mi è successo.
Un pianto per il mio caro amico Marco
e per questa bellezza.
Queste sono lacrime di felicità
e di tristezza.
Io dico sempre che Marco
è una persona con le mani grandi e forti,
ma un cuore molto delicato.
Come detto prima, oso definirmi
creatore di sogni e sorrisi.
È vero.
La delicatezza di una persona
è anche questa.
Una persona deve saper piangere
ed è importante piangere.
E qui siamo in vetta.
Guardate la sfericità della terra.
È una cosa magica,
perché gli alpinisti himalayisti
che salgono là sopra
senza ossigeno sono degli eletti.
Noi saliamo là sopra senza niente.
Viviamo il mondo diversamente.
Questo è il mondo che vede
un alpinista himalayista a 8.167 m.
Un luogo magico.
Questa è la cresta finale.
Mancano 100 metri.
Si esulta là sopra...
perché là sopra si esulta.
Si esulta all'arrivo
di questo grande obiettivo
dopo due mesi di sacrifici,
ma poi, dico sempre io,
spegno un computer, ne attacco un altro,
perché il difficile è tornare a casa vivi.
Quando uno raggiunge la montagna
è a metà dell'opera.
Bisogna ancora scendere.
Per cui disconnetto
e riconnetto un'altra cosa.
Stacco, accendo un computer
e si scende.
Là sotto c'è il campo base,
ma devi ancora avere benzina
per tornare a casa.
Per scendere vivo.
Perché il dono più importante,
che tutti noi abbiamo in questa sala,
ricordatevi, è e resterà
sempre solo uno: la vita.
Tutto il resto non conta niente.
Qui si scende adesso
verso il campo base.
Con tanta felicità logicamente.
Con tanto allenamento
è possibile fare anche questo.
Campo 4, vetta, campo base.
Tutto questo è il mio mondo, la mia vita.
Io vivo per la montagna, che ultimamente
sta diventando quasi una missione
perché parlo tantissimo ai giovani,
il futuro del mondo.
Parlo tantissimo alle aziende.
Porto la mia esperienza di himalayista,
di maestro di sci, di tecnico di soccorso,
di creatore di sogni e sorrisi
nelle aziende
per riuscire a far capire effettivamente
come funziona il mio mondo.
Quando mi parlano di problem solving,
io sorrido.
Perché nel mio mondo
velocemente bisogna risolvere i problemi,
ma per risolverli
bisogna essere connessi, preparati.
Bisogna avere fiducia, responsabilità,
mai mollare, tante di queste cose.
Questo è il mio mondo.
Questa è la luna
che mi ha accompagnato quel giorno
per scendere fino al campo base
del Manaslu in giornata.
La felicità di riuscire a tornare lassù,
quello è il mondo.
E questo è un altro mondo
che mi appartiene.
Io amo i giovani, amo i bambini.
Dopo il disastroso terremoto,
del 25 aprile 2015 in Nepal,
con degli amici abbiamo ricostruito
una scuola per i bambini.
Perché i bambini in Nepal
vorrebbero solo due cose:
mangiare e studiare.
Mangiare e studiare.
Noi italiani siamo riusciti
a fare anche questo,
ricostruire una scuola
per i bambini del Nepal.
(Inglese) Ricordate:
nessun dolore, nessun guadagno.
Grazie.
(Applausi)